foreign
Jessica joins us there Jessica how can
we help
hi
um I am about ten thousand dollars in
debt
um I just recently started working in
September to try to begin paying this
off as I've been a stay-at-home mom
um we me and my husband recently
received taxes we received about eight
thousand dollars
um he paid his credit cards off with
that eight thousand dollars
um and we have some left and we have
about 2 400 and he well we don't agree
um that I should pay
what's left the 2400 on my cards he
feels that it won't help and it won't
put a dent into
um where I'm at and so I just I don't
really know what to do I definitely
a mess and um okay so I'm not sure feels
like if I'm hearing you right there's a
lot of he and there's me
and I'm not hearing any wee as that
feels like this is a big problem
yeah definitely well I'm confused
because you said I have 10 000 in debt
and then he paid off his 8 000 so yeah
you all have debt like if you have ten
thousand it's it's y'all's ten thousand
that's something that's not how you guys
are playing this out correct right
correct and he doesn't want you to take
the remaining 2400 if I heard you right
and put it on your credit card which
would knock it down from 10 to uh what
is the math on that
68 6600 yeah so yeah how do we get to
this point like how how long have you
all been married
we've been
there for
um 10 years
um I think we've gotten to this point
because I tend to be Reckless with money
and I have been and at the same time I
have grown just maybe not that much
um I'm still trying
um but I don't think I think it comes
down to him not trusting me yeah but
wait a second
um and I did my math wrong it would be 7
600 left if you put 2400 on there so why
did he he says that doesn't make a dent
that's a pretty good sized dent
yeah and uh and that would actually
actually leave me with four cards and
two of those cards I've already made
payment plan arrangements with those
credit card companies and um what does
he want you to do with that money
I he wants to save it because he thinks
it would be better for our family
because we're hoping to buy a house soon
because we're currently renting and we
need to bring obviously what we're
paying monthly and living costs down
how's your relationship outside of the
the this issue
um I would say we have a
substantly finances is definitely the
hardest thing to talk about together
Jessica I'm going to ask you a question
I want you to be really honest like take
a you know take a second to self-reflect
you said that he doesn't trust you with
money are you trustworthy at this point
at this point where I'm at yeah like
once this debt is paid off you're gonna
close all these cards yes like they're
going to be gone forever and you're
never going back in debt
no never like have you had that I've had
at moment because we we've seen this
over and over again where people freak
out for a second they pay off their debt
and then they're back in it a year later
yeah no I definitely feel like I've been
here for a while that's why I got a job
in September okay
um so that is why I haven't been able to
catch up because I'm so behind that
minimum payments are 60 plus on nine
cards well and that's the thing is like
you feel the heat now but we want to
make sure even once you're caught up on
payments when you're not just like
feeling this heat that this continues as
a lifestyle so have you all taken
Financial Peace University yet
no okay that's step one and we'll gift
it to you hang on the line after the
call Austin will get it to you and
that'll be our gift to you guys now I
want you all to go through and if you
can find a local community so we have
Financial Peace University happening all
over the country and I want you all to
go in person yeah and go to this class
and walk it out every week at some point
you're gonna have to literally cut up
your credit cards and be done with them
and I want you all to just get on the
same page because I think you're at that
spot where you're ready but this is this
is pretty deep and I mean he is probably
it's like I feel for both I feel you
know you're on the call and you're
wanting to move forward but he also has
legitimate reasons for being a little
bit nervous about this but but the thing
that I'm most concerned about is there's
no Unity on this and this is really
troubling I mean finances are the number
one cause of divorce and you guys you
guys are playing with fire and right I'm
curious do you have separate bank
accounts as well we do we do now yes
okay what do you mean now
we didn't before before what
before I got a job I apologize
so when you got it so so you've done
stuff with money where he supposedly
doesn't or he doesn't trust you and then
you go out and get a job to try to deal
with some of the mess that you've made
and that's when he says let's get
separate accounts
yeah he ended up I'm getting his direct
deposit shifted somewhere else to make
sure that I wouldn't use it was that
during the phase where debt was racking
up
uh
uh yeah because yeah okay so you guys
gotta go see a marital counselor
yes I'm dead serious
because I don't want to unpack all this
for the audience because quite frankly
it doesn't matter we don't need to get
down deep right but you broke Trust
or or
you know what I think you broke trust
but I think he also used it
mm-hmm I could be wrong but both of you
are wounded and acting wounded and and
his while you broke trust the right
response was not for him to go create a
separate account and now you guys have
these two separate things that's not the
right response I want to address that go
see a professional marital counselor and
let's get to the bottom of this because
if he wants to get healthy and you guys
are healthy in every other area of your
marriage then he's going to willingly do
this and you can rewind this and he can
watch this on YouTube but I'll just tell
you bro uh yes she may have wounded you
and you you lost trust but it's not okay
for you to now all of a sudden create
more separation two wrongs don't make a
right and and I get some marital
counseling and I'd shove all those
accounts together I would also tell you
to call these people today when you get
off this phone call and close the cards
okay literally close the accounts
you don't have to pay them off to close
them close them cut the credit cards up
you're never going back to this again
you got to fight for your marriage you
got to fight for your husband's heart
you guys got to fight for Unity on this
do you understand what I'm saying like I
don't want to sugarcoat this I'm not
like getting all uh worked up for no
reason like this is serious serious
stuff do you understand what I'm saying
yeah
yeah and if this stuff isn't okay your
marriage isn't okay like even just with
Ken asking the question of like how is
your marriage outside like it's not okay
if this isn't okay because this is just
like a symptom there's distrust there's
all of these different things going on
and I'm right there with you you need a
counselor and I think in this process
like you're both gonna have to really be
humble like I think you both have your
fists up and you've got you're defensive
and you're cautious and you're
distrusting and it's like this for this
to win for you all to win with your
money like it's going to take humility
with both of you you both are gonna go
we've both done things wrong like we're
both wrong we both have made mistakes we
both have been distrusting and let's
forgive what's happened obviously work
through it with a counselor but at some
point you will have to reach a spot
where you say I forgive you and he
forgives you and then you go let's start
from here like all all the shame all the
guilt all the bad things that have
happened in our past that's behind us
and now we're gonna build like we're
gonna build strong and we're gonna build
fresh and we're not going to hold all
that stuff against each other yeah
Jessica hang on the line we're going to
get you into Financial Peace University
as our gift and
um let's let's commit let's do whatever
it takes for the two of you to go
through this let's also get to some
marital counseling this stuff is all
stuff that you can overcome I don't want
the seriousness of my tone to convey
that it is uh not something you can
overcome but it is very serious that we
overcome it and there are uh many many
people who can help you all certainly in
the Charlotte area let's let's get you
in an fbu class let's also get some
counseling all at the same time I would
treat this as trauma because it is so
thank you for the call hang on we'll
take good care of you
uh folks the numbers don't lie
when you aren't on the same page with
your spouse on money it creates a
tremendous Rift in your relationships
and it is the cause of Many Many of a
divorce so don't just treat this as mine
and yours it's ours